(Transcribed by TurboScribe. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) It's not just that I fancy the subject
matter, so I come and say it before
you know.
It's because he has pointed it to me
for a very long time, very long time
ago.
And it helped me to stand where I
am standing today.
And he has always undertaken for me.
I've shared a few testimonies with you here.
It's not because I can pray.
It's not because I am worth anything.
But it's because Christ died for me, and
I'm a bona fide citizen of the kingdom
of God.
When we talk about the kingdom of God,
as we said last week, what does the
kingdom of God mean?
And what does it mean to you?
We said last week that the word kingdom
is a combination of two words.
King and domain.
A domain, a realm, or an area where
the king is ruling.
That's simply the kingdom.
So don't look at it very far away.
Last week we looked at Matthew chapter 13
verse 44.
Where the Lord Jesus Christ was describing, he
gave us a parable about kingdom.
I don't know, we didn't discuss it, but
I want to remind you that Jesus taught
in parables.
You need to ask yourself, why did our
Lord teach in parables?
I'm sure you know.
One of the reasons why he taught in
parables is so that it will provoke a
desire inside you to know.
To know more.
If it does not provoke a desire for
you to know more, that word is finished
there.
He said to the disciples who were asking
him, why is it that you're always teaching
parables?
I have such a time in myself.
He said, it's given to you to know,
but it's not given to them.
So when he's speaking to people to whom
it's not given, to people who have ears
but they don't hear, people who have eyes
but they don't see, if it does not
wake up a desire for them to know,
that's the end of the matter.
But if it wakes up a desire, he
runs to meet you immediately.
See all these things we are talking about
in church.
When you set out to explore them, the
Lord will meet with you immediately.
And that's why he teaches in parables.
So he gave us a parable of the
man who went to look for a goodly
treasure.
He called it treasure of inestimable value.
And we tried to tell ourselves, what is
a treasure of inestimable value?
Inestimable, you cannot estimate the value of that
treasure.
But the only thing we added to it
was to explain that treasure by the Lord's
word about our soul.
Where he said, what will it profit a
man to gain the whole world and then
lose his soul?
The Lord was saying it that that man
is foolish, who will gain the whole world
and at the end he will lose his
soul.
The Lord was telling us that one soul,
your soul, is greater than the value of
the whole world to him.
Whenever we say this, people don't understand.
Think about it.
Meditate on it because it has to do
with you and me.
The value of your soul to God.
Then bring around you the circumstances that you
are facing and you forget that you are
valued more than the whole world to Christ.
If you are able to remember that, in
any circumstance, that circumstance will die.
That travail will finish.
You will walk through it with no skating,
no bowling, nothing will happen to you.
All because you know the value of your
soul to the Lord Jesus Christ.
So this man found the treasure of inestimable
value where in a field.
This is a field.
Manchester is a field.
So many, but let's not go there.
He found it.
He was so joyful at finding it.
What did he do?
He buried it back, covered it with sand,
and did what?
Ran back to his business, ran back to
his house, sold everything that he had so
that he would do what?
Buy, not the treasure.
He bought the field surrounding that so he
would not contest with anybody, any kingdom, any
desire, any attractions.
No, he bought the entire field because of
that treasure.
In verse 45 again, he gave us another
example of the one that was looking after
a goodly pear.
You know, who found it and did what?
Also went back and sold everything.
And the question we had last week for
you was, look at the responses of these
people who found this thing.
Their response was full of joy.
And we said to ourselves, we have found
the same pear.
We have found the pear of inestimable value.
You and I, you have found it.
You better pronounce that to yourself.
You have found it.
Because that pear is where?
Is inside of you right now.
The precious Holy Spirit, the King that is
eternal, the King that is immortal, the only
true God is inside.
Whether you believe it or not.
You have found it.
But what response are you giving to finding
it?
And the response sometimes is not correct.
Look at the joyful response of those two
in Matthew 13, 44 and 45.
You yourself, what was your response?
Or what is your response?
That was the question we left last week.
We took ourselves to Matthew 6, verse 33
where the Lord was helping us, guiding us,
bringing us into the right line.
Says we should do what?
Seek first the kingdom of God.
And all these things which do not compare,
they will be added to you.
No matter, even if he says it a
hundred times, he is not going to make
you.
You are the one that will prioritise those
things.
He is not going to come and prioritise
your life for you.
You are the one that will take the
decision to say, ah, this is not important.
This is more important for me.
Only you can make that decision.
But the Lord has guided us into it
and that is what he wants to drive
our life.
Finding the kingdom first.
He says because all these things will be
added onto us.
Then we talked about that the kingdom was
the pathway to abundant life.
John chapter 10, verse 10.
The Lord Jesus Christ said, I have come
to give you what?
Life.
And to give it to you more abundantly.
He is the king.
Christ is the king.
You know, Christ is the king.
And if he has come and done something
for you, something that takes care of you,
that's why we call him a true king,
not like the kings of the earth.
A true king takes care of all his
subjects, all his citizens.
Takes care.
What they wear.
What they eat.
Where they live.
He takes care.
That's why he says, look at the birds
of the air.
What about you?
If he takes care of the birds of
the air, the fishes of the sea, why
do you think he wouldn't take care of
you?
The only person he made in his own
image.
Well, we are provoking thoughts here by revising.
Okay.
And we asked last week.
We checked Google last week.
You know, you remember.
Two weeks ago.
Sorry.
Forgive me.
You know.
Two weeks ago.
We checked Google.
What is abundant life?
And when we read what he said abundant
life was, we said, if you found such
a thing, what would you do?
Everybody professed that joy will fill their heart
to receive it.
Isn't that what we said last week?
Okay.
So, the Christian dilemma as we ended up
last week was that we appear to have
found the kingdom, but our response does not
support it.
At best, our response is timid.
Timid.
Because we don't know the value of what
is inside us.
You know.
At best, it is timid.
At best, it is lukewarm.
At best, it is civilised.
Leave those people in Africa that clap hands
and all those things.
You know.
Some people regard it as it's not a
big deal.
This question of a kingdom is not a
Some people will even tell you don't get
carried away by it.
That's our response.
Okay.
And this is what the Bible is talking
about.
Because that man for joy at the revelation,
the man heeded back and went to sell
everything.
That's just a reminder of two weeks ago.
There is more to it, but I cannot
spend my whole time revising what we did
last two weeks.
Okay.
But today, I want to bring something else
to us.
Let us pray.
Precious Heavenly Father, you are our stronghold.
Yes, your word says that when troubles come,
you are our hiding place.
But that same word says that you will
never, we know you, faithful God, that you
will never forsake those who put their trust
in you.
Father, we put our trust in you.
You said if we acknowledge you and put
our trust in you, you will direct our
paths.
Precious Father, as we listen to your word
today, we ask for a direction to our
paths.
That we may live and bring praise and
glory to your holy name.
We have prayed in Jesus' name.
Amen.
There is more to it, but I have
to stop there because we can't take it
all.
But that was last week.
I brought my notes from last two weeks.
Today, I would like us to go a
little bit more.
That was introductory.
That was introductory two weeks ago.
To the kingdom of God.
And it's everything.
It's everything you should be focused on.
As a Christian.
If you haven't been focussing, begin.
Begin.
Let it occupy at least 80% of
your Bible study time.
You know, I challenged you two weeks ago.
And I said, if you Googled, does anybody
remember that?
If you Googled King James Version of the
Bible.
The old King James Version.
And you put the word, in inverted commas,
enter into the kingdom.
If you search the King James Bible with
that, it will give you 13 references.
And 12 of that 13 references emanate from
the Lord Jesus Christ.
And why did I choose that?
I chose that because it's what he revealed
to me.
And I have studied it.
I don't know, from maybe 1984, 1985.
It stipulates various conditions that will enable you
to enter and inherit the kingdom.
And we said two weeks ago that, according
to the scripture we also read this morning.
You are born into this world, are you
not, by your mother.
There was water breaking before you came out
of the womb.
This world is a place, isn't it?
This physical world is a realm.
And that's the one you are born into.
We said this two weeks ago.
And we said for the kingdom of God,
the Lord Jesus Christ instructed Nicodemus and all
of us.
Because the kingdom of God is a place,
isn't it?
It's a realm.
It's not a physical place.
Like this world is a physical place.
But the kingdom of God, like we talked
about, king domain.
A domain where the king is ruling.
So the kingdom of God, like the Lord
Jesus Christ says, does not come with observation.
If anybody tells you the kingdom of God
is here or there, don't listen to them.
Jesus said because the kingdom of God is
where?
In you.
The kingdom of God is in you.
What does that mean?
The king is in your heart.
Waiting to rule over your life.
He has died for you.
He's given his life for you.
Now you that are alive, you've been exchanged
on the cross.
The life you should live should be the
life of Christ.
If you're not living the life of Christ,
you are wasting the blood of Jesus Christ.
It's true.
It's not a reproach.
I just want you to think about it.
If you are not living for Christ, Galatians
2 verse 20 tells us that we have
been crucified with Christ.
Yes.
Anybody who is saved, anybody who is born
again, has chosen what happened on the cross.
Believed what happened on the cross, is standing
on it.
That's why our sins are cleansed.
Not only sins of yesterday, but sins of
today and sins of tomorrow.
It's been cleansed.
They will no longer hold you.
So that you will abandon yourself and surrender
to God.
So that God who is already inside you
can live through you.
I hope you're getting me.
I'm not going to preach.
I'm just going to try my best to
teach because this is something that should be
taught.
So, we said the kingdom of God is
entered by a new birth.
Okay.
Nicodemus said to the Lord Jesus Christ in
John chapter 3, which we read this morning,
verse 3 and verse 5.
He said, except you are born again, you
will not see the kingdom of God.
In verse 5, he says, except you are
born of water, physical birth, according to Brodoby.
Many theologians have their own interpretation, but that's
my own interpretation.
And I know that by the spirit that
I'm right.
Except you are born physically, you cannot be
born again.
Okay.
Did you get me?
You're first born physically as you are.
By your mother, you are brought into this
world.
You are brought into this physical realm.
And Jesus was telling Nicodemus, except you are
born again.
Many people get lost in thinking about that
concept.
Nicodemus got lost too.
Remember what he said?
Lord Jesus Christ, what do you mean?
Do you mean as you enter back into
my mother's womb and be born?
No, he's not talking about being born into
the same realm.
You've been born into this realm.
The realm of the earth.
That's not what he's talking about.
He's talking about the spirit realm.
So also, into the kingdom of God, you
have to be born into it.
Oh yes, that's why you must be born
again.
Hallelujah.
Yes, we must be born again.
Now, you ask yourself, what is the evidence
that somebody is born again?
In other words, if you're born again, you
believe what Christ did for you on the
cross.
That he carried your sins.
Therefore, you no longer live for yourself, but
you live for him.
So the evidence of being born again, for
instance, is obedience.
Obedience to the word of God.
Obedience to the word of your king.
It's the king that is inside you that
wants to rule.
For him to rule, you have to hear
his word.
And you have to do what?
Obey it.
If you hear his word and you don't
obey it, he's not ruling.
You are ruling.
Hello?
So it's formed through surrender.
You know that favourite song we sing at
altar calls?
I surrender all.
My blessed saviour, I surrender.
That's actually what is happening at your new
birth.
When you become born again, that is the
de facto effect it should have on you.
You surrender.
Acknowledge that the king lives inside you and
the king is able to talk to you.
He's able to guide you.
He's able to teach you.
Remember?
John chapter 14, verse 26.
The Lord Jesus Christ said, it's better for
you that I go away.
So that the father will send his promise.
When I go away, I will send another
comforter.
Who is the Holy Spirit.
When he comes, verse 26 says, he will
teach you all things.
And will bring to bear upon your remembrance
everything he has said.
So it's not a hard job.
If you allow the king who is inside,
the spirit of the king is inside.
The Holy Spirit is not physical.
Yeah?
The Holy Spirit is a spirit.
You are his body.
You are the body that he uses.
And he's already inside.
So every decision that is facing you, he
already knows it.
What he's waiting for is what will be
your response.
Every decision.
Please, I'm not excluding anything.
Every decision that faces you in life.
He wants to guide you.
I share my testimony here.
27th of July, 1987 was the date I
knew that the Holy Spirit was inside me.
The date I knew that he talked.
He talked.
I shared my testimony of the conception of
my wife here.
Didn't I?
I didn't know he talked.
I didn't know he was inside.
I didn't know that he wanted to guide
my life.
I don't like sharing this testimony about prayer
because sometimes people think it's not necessary to
pray.
Oh, I pray.
I pray.
But most of the times when he intervenes,
I can't look back and say I was
praying and fasting before he said something to
me.
Because something was going to threaten his destiny
for me.
He came to give me information.
Immediately.
What remains is whether you take that information
or whether you stick by it and continue
to walk.
He wants to guide you.
He wants to lead you.
This is not preaching, my brothers and my
sisters.
It's something you must actualise for yourself.
Because that is the whole essence of being
a Christian.
If he doesn't guide you or direct you,
you're what?
Not only lost.
Because that's the way the children of this
world or the simple English says you are
a bastard.
You don't have a father.
But if you have a father, you must
listen to your father and take guidance.
So, we said two weeks ago.
I'm sorry.
I'm just refreshing you so that it will
impact you.
We said two weeks ago that Jesus did
not preach any other thing.
He didn't preach religion.
He preached the kingdom.
We refer to John the Baptist, right?
When John the Baptist came, what did he
preach?
The kingdom of God is near.
Near.
All of you, change your mind.
And we say changing your mind is change
your perspective to life.
If you don't change your perspective to life,
you cannot see that kingdom.
Neither can you enter it.
In other words, you're going this way.
And John the Baptist is telling you the
kingdom is communal.
You must stop going this way.
You must repent.
And go towards where you know that the
kingdom is.
That's what it means to change your mind.
I mean to repent.
You change your mind about the way you're
going.
You must change your mind.
You cannot continue going the way you're going
and expect to be inside the kingdom.
No.
It calls for repentance.
Now, we said that Jesus did not preach
religion.
Or a distant dream.
You know some of us think the kingdom
of God is when we die.
How Jesus will welcome us into the kingdom.
No, it's not a distant dream.
It's something that is happening now.
That's why you must change your mind.
That's why you must change your perspective.
When you do, oh, you see the fruit
that will come from it.
I used to say to people, I would
have died long ago.
I would have died a despicable death.
It's not that death is anything.
But I would have been lost.
But the Lord was gracious to me to
show me.
There's a decision that will come in front
of you.
In fact, not a decision that will come.
There is where your heart is.
Your heart is going this way.
But the Lord instructed me that that is
not his way.
I was chasing to become an executive director
of a bank.
And he stopped me.
You are after money.
Of course, I've earned money.
I've worked for international organisations.
Worked for conglomerate commercial concerns.
Consulted for...
So my heart was moving in the direction
of money.
Because it was money that was ruling.
He says, no, that's not my plan for
you.
But if you want to continue going that
way, this is what is waiting for you.
He showed me.
It's not that one is afraid of death.
But it's what kind of death.
I surrendered to him.
I said, father, I'm sorry.
I can't tell you more.
There's a lot I could say to explain
what I'm saying.
But I just said, father, no, I will
not go that way anymore.
I stopped chasing that job.
Then the following day, I was called into
the work of missions.
Not the following day.
About two weeks later.
And since then, I've been in mission.
Because that's his plan for my life.
Even the work I did in international organisation.
Banking and all those.
He also arranged it himself.
He was God that directed me there.
If I don't have time.
But when you get into bank and get
to all those money places, your heart begins
to buy into money.
But it's not everybody that has that route.
You must find your route and stick to
it.
And God was telling me, that's not my
route for you.
It may be for other people.
But not for you.
I can tell you that since that time
in 1998, nobody has paid me a salary.
Nobody.
Nobody can boast they paid me a salary.
Till today.
Why am I telling you this?
We talk about glorious riches in Christ Jesus.
We are talking about we living in Christ
Jesus.
Christ in you, the hope of glory.
Everything I do, I obey the king.
If the king has not provided what I
need to do that thing.
The bible says, the king does not send
you to war at your own cost.
That's Jesus.
He doesn't send you to war at your
own cost.
If you are going to war and it's
at your own cost, that is not Jesus.
You need to check yourself.
That's your own war that you are going
to.
But whenever he sends you to war, he's
already paid the price.
He's paid the cost.
If I'm supposed to come to UK, the
money will be there.
I don't earn a salary to buy a
ticket.
But the money for that ticket will be
there.
Somehow.
It's only when you look for it in
a particular way, that you find that you're
in trouble.
But if you're open, surrender to the lord.
If ticket comes, we go.
If it doesn't come, we will not go
now.
We sit down.
I'm trying to use the word importance.
It is of more importance to him than
you.
He's the one that is asking you to
go.
So why should you now go and do
or die to buy a ticket?
No.
It's you that is doing or dying, not
him.
If he wants you to be in UK,
you'll be there.
I used to advise some of our people
here in UK.
Many people who follow crooked ways to stay.
I said, no.
The fact that you desire to be here,
means that the lord wants you to be
here.
Because you have the lord inside.
The king is inside you.
And if that desire is desiring to be
here, please my brother, go home.
Go home, do the right thing, you'll be
back here.
Properly.
Without fear of anybody.
And it's not once.
Many people have taken that advice.
And they've seen the lord in action.
Because sometimes we want to do it by
ourselves.
But we forget that the king is in
here.
And he does all things right.
Okay.
Alright.
So.
I want to.
I was saying that Jesus did not preach
anything else apart from the kingdom.
John the Baptist came, preached the kingdom.
When Jesus came, he also preached about the
kingdom of God.
It's here.
It's no longer near.
Because it's been fulfilled in him.
He is the king.
That is eternally, immortal, the only true God.
The lord Jesus Christ.
That's all he preached.
What did his disciples preach?
What did the apostles like Paul, what did
they preach?
The only thing, please.
No matter what you.